thank you very much
thank you Yvette thank you all of you
it's all fantastic to see you all here
this morning to be here in burslem the
mother town of the potteries where yeah
where the Spades first hit the ground in
the construction of the great Trent and
mersey Canal uh a fact which of course
gives its name to Port Vale although for
me if I'm honest this is better known as
the ground where Arsenal came really
close to losing the double in 1998. this
is this is true
two drawers in the cup and a penalty
shootout very close penalty shootout
somewhere just over there I went out to
have a look at the pitch this morning to
look at where those penalties were taken
from
um but today we are here on more serious
business as Yvette said the launch of
Labor's Second National mission to make
our streets safe and stop criminals
getting away without punishment
now
now if you think that sounds basic
something which should be guaranteed in
a country like ours
then let me tell you you're right
nothing is more important more
fundamental to a democracy like ours the
rule of law is the foundation for
everything
Margaret Thatcher called it the first
duty of government and she was right
about that an expression of individual
liberty our rights and responsibilities
but also Justice fairness equality
one rule for all
that's the principle I've been proud to
serve all my adult life
as a human rights layer fighting for
families with young children trying to
escape mold infested accommodation
author freedom of speech in the most
libel case
with the Police Service of Northern
Ireland advising them how to bring
communities together to make the Good
Friday agreement work
and at the crown prosecution Service as
the Director of public prosecutions
the same process principle
everyone protected everyone respected no
one denied the law no one above the law
not the murderers of Stephen Lawrence
who for a Time thought that they were
not Al-Qaeda terrorists
not MPS labor or conservatives gaming
the expenses system to line their
pockets I prosecuted them all and I'm
proud of that one role for all
right and that's what I found the
pandemic parties in Downing Street under
Boris Johnson so reprehensible
the circus of the last few days
a reminder of his is total disrespect
for a national sacrifice
that's why I said I'd resign if I'd
broken those same rules
I just couldn't have looked the British
people in the eye and asked them for
their trust
those values are too important to me
the core of my politics today
so if the Tories want to attack me for
being a human rights lawyer attack the
values I've stood up for my whole life
I say fine
that only shows how far they have fallen
and how little they understand working
people
[Applause]